des paysages bucoliques l'air frais de
la campagne
de quoi charmer les cyclistes et des
piétons qui empruntent le p'tit train du
nord à val david
mais ces jours-ci ce paisible tronçon
est cause de controverse le progrès
maintenant c'est plus l'asphalt ses
dépenses et isabelle mouilleseaux fait
partie d'un comité de citoyens qui se
disent à la défense du petit train du
nord à la défense parce que ce tronçon
doit bientôt être asphaltée ça va
accélérer la circulation salaire que ça
roule jusqu'à 40 km heure les pelotons
avec les superbes cycle est déjà là y en
a peu qui nous disent tant ses voûtes
ainsi voûté 65% du p'tit train du nord
qui redit les basses laurentides à mont
laurier est déjà asphaltée les travaux
doivent commencer à val david dans une
dizaine de jours
seize kilomètres de val morin à sainte
agathe des monts qui seront revêtus
d'asphalt d'ici le mois d'octobre selon
la corporation responsable du sentier
l'idée est de rendre la piste plus
accessible la salle d'un accès à un plus
grand nombre d'utilisateurs
que ce soit les vélo la marche
l'euro le blé donc décidé de
démocratiser les usages et jean
sébastien thibault estime que
l'asphaltage prolongera l'accès à la
piste de trois à cinq semaines par année
nicolas joly a étudié l'impact
environnemental pour la mrc des
laurentides
il était lui même réticent à
l'asphaltage au début ce point critique
mais c'est un meilleur choix
environnemental parce que l'érosion la
criblure dans nos cours d'eau sont
beaucoup plus nocif que parce que c'est
pas un matériel qui est stabilisé
l'option de pierrelatte toutes les fois
qu'une pluie serrures dans
l'environnement ont contraint la sfap
vont rester très stable isabelle nos
jours n'est pas convaincu pour autant
elle dit avoir récolté des centaines de
signatures pour sa pétition qui demande
aux élus de mettre les travaux en veille
le temps de consulter les citoyens
davantage on marche puis c'est
complètement en harmonie avec le milieu
c'est extrêmement important par rapport
au patrimoine visuel et quant aux
usagers de la piste on est content
bike banques nous on recherche les
sentiers non asphaltées je suppose parce
que moi c'est un vélo de route puis j'ai
dit avant d'aller sur des surfaces comme
l'ain sont pas en asphalte mais
asphaltée c'est sûr que ça serait un
avantage s'est déjà taillé khl parce que
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de cyclistes
puis vont il y en a beaucoup que vous
levez la mrc des laurentides pied ce
soir une séance d'information pour
répondre aux questions et aux
inquiétudes des citoyens et le comité
qui se posent à l'asphaltage de la piste
qu ont profité de l'occasion pour
remettre en personne leur pétition aux
élus ici m caron radio canada val david